dans cette campagne tranquille on serait
loin d'imaginer des tremblements de
terre pourtant le dernier a frappé il ya
seulement deux jours reina fini par s'y
habituer depuis une trentaine d'années
plus de 1500 séisme ont été ressenties
pendant l'un des tremblements de terre
cette porte ne voulait plus ouvrir et je
voulais sortir parce que j'entendais les
murs se fissurent est si fort que
j'avais l'impression qu'il fallait
vraiment que je sorte que la maison
entière allait s'écrouler et depuis le
début de la guerre en ukraine reina est
encore plus inquiètes à trois kilomètres
de là se trouve le gisement gazier de
groningue l'un des plus grands d'europe
son exploitation devait cesser cette
année car c'est justement elle qui
causent les tremblements de terre mais
avec les menaces russe sur
l'approvisionnement en gaz des européens
elle pourrait au contraire augmenté une
bonne option selon ce spécialiste
d'un point de vue strictement technique
c'est une forme de compromis que la
société néerlandaise doit faire
est ce qu on augmente la production à
groningue pour moins dépendre de la
russie mais avec le risque d'engendrer
plus de tremblements de terre
une perspective difficile à appréhender
pour les habitants de la région qui
craignent pour leur avenir
si on nous coupe le gaz russe ça va
créer un plus gros problème ici
plus de gaz sera pompée à groningue et
c'est nous qui allons nous retrouver
sous des tentes comme cet habitant aussi
s'inquiète car il a récemment dû quitter
sa maison devenue trop dangereuse malgré
tout il veut aussi se montrer solidaire
il faut aussi que l'on pense à nos
voisins européens
qui suis-je pour dire que nous n'allons
pas exploité de gaz alors qu'à deux
heures de vol d'ici les gens meurent
parce que la russie bombarde leur pays
il y encore 450 milliards de mètres
cubes de gaz à exploiter juste sous mes
pieds malgré l'inquiétude des habitants
de la région une récente étude a montré
que deux tiers de la population serait
d'accord pour augmenter l'exploitation
est ainsi moins dépendre du gaz russe